제 주변에 건물주 분들이 많기 때문에
한번 다 여쭤 봤어요 그랬더니 어
소개를 해 달라 그러면은 소개를 안
해 줘요 다 의가 상한 거야
[음악]
벌써네 안녕하세 사나입니다 어 제가
오늘은 저희 bsn 설계하고 시공한
현장이 좀 와 있는데 저희 이따가
건축주분이 좀 오셔요 그래가지고 좀
이렇게 그 공사 관련돼서 회의 하기로
했는데 오늘 좀 겸사겸사 어 회의도
하면서 좀 건축주분 인터뷰를 좀 딸
예정입니다 건축주분이 아마 되게
유명하신 분이에요 아마 다들 아실 것
같은데 이따가 제가 공개하겠습니다
지금 올해 3월 달에 이제 중공
예정이거든요 그래서 그거 맞춰 가지고
중공이 좀 완료될 거 같습니다 그래서
지금 보면은 사실 대지면적이 좀
그렇게 크진 않은데 어 최대한 면적을
뺀 부분이 있고 그리고 이따가 저희
그 김준석 소장님도 좀 오거든요
그래서 김준석 소장님한테 좀 설계에
대해서 어 간단하게 인터뷰도 따고
그다음 이제 건축주분 실제로 공사 좀
좀 어떠셨는지 어 저희가 한번 좀
인터뷰를 따도록 하겠습니다네 어 저희
김준석 소장님을 모셨습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 지금이 건물을 설계했는데
좀 어떤 식으로 좀 설계했는지 좀
설명해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 어
일단은 저희 건물 같은 경우에는 좀
최단 시간 내에 가성비 있게
설계하는게 가장 큰 목표였고 가성
비게 한다고 하지만 또 건물이 다른
건물들에 비해서 또 빛나지 않으면 안
되니까 그런 부분에 대해서도
외관적으로 디자인에 좀 신경을
썼습니다 주변 맥락도 좀 고려해서
비슷한 재료 를 좀 선정을 했고요
흔히 보실 수 있는 붉은 벽돌이 그
부분에 있어서 어떤 식으로 디자인
포인트를 줄지 건축주께서 의견을
굉장히 많이 주셔서 디자인 협의에
많이 참여를 해 주셨습니다 그래서
그런 것들을 조합해서 최종적인
디자인들을 이제 결정을 했었고 지상
계층을 확보함으로 인해서 용적률은
최대로 다 확보를 한 그런 케이스예요
대신에 이제 공사비에 대한 좀 절간
부분이 있었고 최대한 빠른 시간 내
공사를 진행하고 있는 그런
프로젝트입니다 창을 좀 많이 낸 거
같아요네 그래서 지금 여기 보시면은
이제 다 창으로 되어 있고
베란다가 생각보다 넓어요 저이 정도로
넓을지 몰랐는데 이게 결국은 1조
사선 제한 때문에 후퇴되는 부분이긴
한데네 어쨌든 용적률이 저희가 꽉 차
있다 보니까 그 최상층을 최대한 넓게
쓰면서 하부층 있는 지붕을 베란다로
활용하는 그런 케이스입니다 여기
공간도 되게 잘 활용할 수 있을 것
같아요 와 이거 생각보다 진짜 넓어서
깜짝 놀랐어요 기 부분도 좀 활용이
잘 될 거 같고 그다음에 지금 외벽에
이제 벽돌로 하긴 했는데 요즘에 근데
벽돌이 또 워낙 잘 나오고 되게 세련
되더라고요네 예전 벽돌들이 좀
촌스러운 그런 스타일의 벽돌은
아니고요 벽돌 자체에 질감도 있고 또
색상도 많이 다양하게 나오기 때문에
우리가 잘만 선정을 한다면은 좋은
외장재로 활용할 수 있습니다 그리고
처음부터 우리가 건물의 용도를 어느
정도 지정을 했잖아요 그래서 사무실
용도로 쓰기 위네 위해서 이제 지정을
하고서는 계획을 하다 보니 창호를 좀
많이 설치한 거 같아요 그래서 뭐
설계 관련돼서 여기까지 하고 아마
이제 가림막이 철거된 다음에 이제 좀
본격적으로 모습을 보여줄 수 있을 것
같습니다 그리고 이제 건축주 분을
모셔서 좀 건축주분 인터뷰도 간단히
딸 예정인데 일단 회의하러
내려가시고네네 요거요 우리 그때
선택했던 지냈던 예 진 이거 때 봤던
거보다 조금 더 진한 색
아 어떠세요 너무 그 그 밝지 않고
그거보다 한 톤 더 진한 색상이고요
거친 느낌이 나는 타이어요 그때 여러
개 비교했을 때는 막는데 이것만
있으니까 딱
붙여야 그리고 사실 사실 우리가 그때
봤던게 잘 기억이 안
나시죠네 그래서 요걸로 시공을 할
예정이고요 내부에 들어갈 타이를 좀
안쪽에서 보시면 될 지금 아까 화장실
보셨잖아요 너 와서 이걸로 화장실
시공을 하게 되면은 몇 장이 안
들어가요 그래도 이렇게 사이즈 큰
걸로 좀 가고 싶다 하시면은 최대한
맞춰놓는 볼 텐데 고게 조금
시공성으로 따지면 조금 작은 걸로
가는게 어떨까 싶어서 한번 말씀을
드려 보려 고기 더 넓어 보이는게
어떤 고게 넓어 보이는 거는 큰
사이즈가 넓어
보 어떤 크기가 더 괜찮으세요 어떤
걸 추천하세요
거 딱 다이 안아서네 만약에 바닥을
작은 걸로 가신다면 저는 버그는 예요
사이즈로 가시는게 조금 더 그래야
이제 바닥하고 벽하고 요렇게 라인에
맞춰서 올릴 수가 있으니까 예 그게
조금 더 나을 거 같고 그래도 좀
큰게 좋다 하시면은 둘 다 큰
사이즈로가 버리는게 다 큰게 300에
300으로 하는게 공적으로는 맞습니다
이게 너무 작아 보여서 걱정이 된다
싶지만 않으시면 일반적으로도 많이 는
그런 사이즈라서이 이렇게 가셔도
괜찮을
거네 그럼 바닥은 3각으로 하고
3각으로가 벽은 이제 300 되는데
색상을 결정하셔야 돼요 밝은 색상이
좋으신지 어두운 색상이 좋으신지
일반적으로 저희가 바닥은 조금 때가
많이 타니까 어두운 계열 벽은 좀
밝은 계약을 쓰는데 작은 화장실에서는
한 색깔로 통일하고 이런 색깔이 다
있다고 생각하니까 되게 어두워 보이죠
그죠 이거는 좀 어두워
밝은색상 거 같은데 아니면은 지금
보여드린 것처럼
런 인자 타입도
있어요 리 지금 여기 너무 어두운
거요 조형 때문에 더 그렇게 오 것
같아
밝은 거는 너무 밝고 너무 밝 걸로
통일되는 건
위
[음악]
아네 저희가 건축주 분을 오셨습니다
안녕하세요네 안녕하십니까 아마 다들
잘 아실 것 같은데 간단하게 좀 소개
부탁드리겠습니다네 스마트튜브 부동산
조사 연구소 김학률 수장입니다
반갑습니다네네 그래서 이번에 건물을
좀 처음 신축하는 거잖아요 그래서 좀
이번에 처음 신축하는데 좀 이렇게 뭐
심정이 좀 어떠신지 좀 궁금합니다
저도 이제 뭐 아파트는 뭐 수도 없이
많이 해보고 뭐 상가나 뭐 다른
형태들은 해봤는데 건물 신축에 대해서
좀 관심은 많았었고 해보려고 했었는데
어 좀 여치가 않았었는데 마침 적당한
건물이 나왔고요 그리고 이제 처음에는
이제이 건물을 리모델링을 할까
했었는데 제 2종인데 용적률을 반도
못 찾아 먹었더라 그요 그래서 좀
그래서 이제 어 빌사남 대표님하고
김수 대표님하고 상의를 했는데 신축
한기 좋겠다고 지환을 받았었고 그래서
어 일단은 어차피 해볼 거 어 좋은
입제 해 보고 싶어서 아 주 지금
이제 골까 다 올라갔네요 아무튼 어
예 잘 진행되고 있습니다네 그래서 좀
많은 분들이 이렇게 신축에 대해서 좀
이렇게 걱정이 많잖아요 그리고 이제
뭐 신축하면 뭐 10년 늦는다 뭐
이런 얘기도 있는데이 좀 진행하면서
좀 이렇게 어려웠던 적 점이나 뭐
그런 부분이 있을까요 아무래도 이제이
건물을 한 번도 신축을 해보지 않으신
분들 같은 경우 용어부터 좀 낯설 거
같고요 때에 또 이제 건축 용어라
아니면 또 과정이라든지 이런 것들 전
정보 전혀 없고 그리고 이제 보통
관심이 있다 하더라도 안 좋은 소리만
듣지 칭찬을 듣는 경우를 더 담원도
못 봤거든요 그래서 이게 야 건물주가
되는게 보통 일은 아니구나 잘 모르는
상태에서 협상을 해 봐야 되니까 이게
또 설계 부분도 있고 시공 부분도
있고 감리 부분도 있고 여러가 다행한
부분들이 있을 텐데 또 연결되는 과정
과장 또 잘 모르잖아요 그래서 좀
이렇게 한꺼번에 좀 해결할 수 있는
방법들을 찾다 보니까 다행히 저는
이제 지인들이 워낙 훌륭하신 분이
많아 가지고 도움을 많이 받았던 거
같고요 더군다 하나 또 여기 bsn
대표님 께서 많이 도와주셔 가지고
원만하게 잘 진행됐던 거 같고 그래서
다른 분들이 그렇게 저한테 막 또
어떻게 괜찮겠냐고 우려했던 것들보다는
큰 뭐 걱정 없이 무탈하게 잘
진행됐었던 거 같고 오히려 저는 그냥
새로운 거 배우는 걸 좋아하다 보니까
한번 하고 나니까 다음에 더 잘할 수
있을 것 같은 용기가 생겨서 어 두
번째 건물은도 잘 질 것 같습니다네
아 감사합니다 그래서 일단은 뭐
저희한테 맡겨 주셔서 너무 감사드리고
조만간에 이제 좀 그 뭐 타일 외
외벽을 좀 붙이고 좀 하면은 이제
가림막 철거한 다음에 이제 외벽
모습도 좀 보여 줄 수 있을 것
같은데 그때 좀 다시 한번 좀 모셔
가지고 한번 좀 이렇게 촬영을 좀
하면 좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 이제
사남 tvs도 나가지만 아마 스마트
TV 나갈 거거든요 어 그죠 잘
만드셔야 돼요 예 20 20만 명이
지켜보고 있으니까 20만 명한테 어떤
인상을
주실지네 그래서 완성된 어 모습도
기대해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
인터뷰는 여기까지 하겠습니다네
맙습니다네 감사합니다네네